sayshe in a way sounds like I don't know
I'd rather shake
it's 2018 and RuPaul's Drag Race is
doing better than ever and they're
pretty mainstream now a particular group
of people who is a little bit confused
though about this show is straight man
they seem to know what it is but not
really understand it so I invited four
straight man to come in here and make us
believe that they know RuPaul's Drag
Race we're gonna show them a few clips
from the show and then we're gonna throw
questions that done they can't say they
don't know the answer so if they don't
know what I'm talking about they have to
make me believe that they know the show
good luck and don't get up
all right so the premise of RuPaul's
Drag Race is wait 10 or so drag queens
uh come to see who is the next drag
superstar so people do drag race yeah
and they try to win to become part of
RuPaul's cool there are separate
challenges on each show and you get
judged by a panel of judges well being
one of the judges and then have guest
judges from America's Next Top Model and
sometimes ariana grande international
competitors come in and it's a it's
amazing it's sort of like a team battle
at first and then it comes down to sort
of head to head by the end and at the
end somebody's got to win and RuPaul is
the ultimate drag queen right she has a
whole company of drag queens they win a
bunch of makeup and then and then they
also get like bragging rights a battle
of wits visual effects makeup effects
where the most accurate and poised
look when I just on taste a you kidding
me on Saturday wait let's get kicked off
the Shutts like you've been voted off of
Survivor I don't know I don't want you
survivor okay all i watch is RuPaul's
Drag Race sayshe in a way sounds like I
don't know
I rather shades they I'd be it ask -
Shante stay until I was Queen was the
drag race I would prefer to sashay away
mainly because I heard John Mulaney say
it Shante stand because sashay away
means you're eliminated I think it's one
maxi-challenge
because if you win the maxi challenge
you get to choose someone to eliminate
the better is five mini challenges you
got to win I think you should hear the
mini challenges are the even though the
the max leaves at the max each other
winning one maxi challenge if you're
gonna go and do something you gotta be
number one you got to go and you got to
leave on top I mean you got to go big
you gotta win the maxi challenge is
right you can win mini challenges all
day long but at the end of the day maxi
challenge is really where you're gonna
get any sort of progress in power right
[Music]
will be my track I'm Meghan I've been
eager dohsa every to Eureka
Riki Tiki Rica
[Music]
that would be big cactus
[Music]
jira Rafferty because like giraffe to be
Giro Rafferty because I'm tall
[Music]
getting to experience something that's
outside of your point of view is super
important and I know that I have gotten
such a perspective on this world that I
didn't even know existed exploring like
emotions and the actual personalities
and the human beings behind like drag
culture I think it's very important
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]